the question I was asked was our idea of
the intention of rebooting every
successful franchise you've ever done
and I said you bet your ass I have so
this cover story comes out just in time
for Blade Runner 20 49 let's start with
the $64,000 question I mean this is the
third film franchise you've returned to
this 135 years after the original what
well I'm just wondering what a problem
with that it's a living how does it make
you feel that audiences want to see you
return to these roles like Indy like han
Solo
like Rick Deckard feels good feels
really good these characters mean a ton
to your fans do you feel nostalgic about
returning to them or do you sort of try
to approach it like well this is almost
like a new character that 35 years on
I'm not gonna be the same person I am
now
it's the same thing only better I heard
that you punched Ryan on the set of
Blade Runner he stepped on my foot and I
just tagged him and he went out like a
light no I'm the Star Wars movie a
hydraulic door fell on you and you ended
up KL tell my ass smooshed I think is
the technical term you and Steven
Spielberg reuniting for 50 Indiana Jones
film in 2019 is there anything we can
say about Indy at this stage in his life
and what he's up to
no indeed Eckhart or Han Solo which is
the most fun to play don't really have
favourites your earring it's out why
because I lost it there was a bit of a
runway mishap a few months ago he's
still flying as much or gonna fly all
the time if you're watching TV and one
of your old movies comes on do you watch
yeah sometimes I watch a little bit not
a lot how does it make you feel old is
the experience of coming back to Blade
Runner at all comparable to coming back
to Star Wars I'm a little sentimental
but I'm not missing what cute good start
alright